I was wondering since there's lots of
other genres of podcasts if you were to
the three of you together were to do
another genre of podcasts what would it
be and what would it be called well I
have a very strong opinion about this
and I think I know stone is going to
agree
Sona and I have known each other for 14
years I think yeah and like the first
day Sona worked for me we started
talking about our favorite murders
and we really got into the Weeds about
murders yeah and and and crime scenes
and we uh drove
um to uh one of the murder famous murder
houses in L.A I was worried that you
were gonna like call the next day and
say I don't want to work for this guy he
took me to a murder house yeah but you
knew more than I did and you knew
exactly where to go you're like no no
take a left here now take a right take a
left and then you had a gun for reasons
yeah no kidding and you made it really
creepy you wore a hat you made me turn
off the headlights and we creeped up
there because you didn't want to be seen
looking at this house that's not
something people need to hear okay
it turned out the murder happened later
on and it's still unsolved I see they're
looking for two people a tall Irishman
and an Armenian lady
um no but I I think you and I could talk
True Crime forever and I I love True
Crime it's it is uh
uh um I I'm naturally obsessed with it I
I love trying to figure out what
happened and so that would be the genre
that I might pick I don't know about you
that's exactly what I thought when that
question was first asked was murder and
you know but I we'd have to have an
angle well what if our angle is each
week you and I try to murder Gourley
[Laughter]
maybe we succeed maybe we don't
but whatever happens we then talk about
it afterwards I'm just surprised to hear
you guys don't want to do a Star Wars
podcast
is that really the one you would want to
do no no I'd be happy to do that one
probably right unless it's not important
let's do a question next do you have
no murder sounds fun I like murder too
should we go to the houses and then
knock on the doors and then talk to the
people who live in these murder there's
so many murder houses in L.A yeah we
could uh inform people that they're
living in a murder house which would be
fun because you'd hear them realize that
they're you'd hear them in real time uh
understanding that their house value
just plummeted
very near very nearer to a murder house
and for a while the tenants were renting
and they didn't know they were living in
a murder house and I was yes you know
what you're it is a law you're supposed
to divulge that I think just for sales
though not for renters and you have to
know to ask like that's true you have to
ask yeah I think a show where we go to
murder houses and stay the night and
spend the night with the people yes
against their will in their beds yeah
yes and like like JB Smith said we make
them our friends yes
yeah no I think it would be some kind of
it would be some kind of show like that
murder me much you know some kind of
title like that how about the cone
collector the cone oh come on come on
could it play on The Bone Collector oh
sorry did you understand my meaning when
you have a problem with it it's just it
was just it was just I like murder me
much it sounds sort of like a dating
show and we could put like a funny font
on it put some hearts murder me much
okay yeah I mean it doesn't none of
these titles really mean anything no
better really needy